[Music]
silocyben the psychedelic compound found
in magic mushrooms helps to open up
depressed people's brains for up to
three weeks
this enables brain regions to talk more
freely to one another that's according
to a new uk study published in the
journal nature medicine
if you look at the landscape of hills
and valleys
the valleys seem very deep in depression
and people get locked into the valley
thinking now psychedelics flatten that
landscape
this is the first time people have
looked to see what happens afterwards
and it seems that that
breaking down of the thinking rutted
thinking the flattening of the landscape
allows persists after when people get
well and that is we call increased
flexibility their brain can work
more fluidly and we think that underpins
the the benefit of cytosimin and
probably other psychedelics and
depression
the results are based on brain scans of
nearly 60 people receiving treatment for
depression who also receive
psychotherapy for mental health
professionals
so how does it compare to traditional
treatments for depression
drugs that are typically used to treat
depression they often fail to
improve symptoms
research shows that one in three
patients on antidepressants
never achieves a full recovery and for
those people who need further treatment
the relapse rate is very high
so this study paves the way for the
condition to be treated differently from
conventional medications the researchers
want to find out how long the effect
lasts and
how the treatment could could be used
and so doctors then would be able to
either offer patients to take a pill
every day or or maybe
take psychedelics every few months
the effects of psychedelics have been
known for some time her research until
recently has been curved
it's extremely disappointing that it's
taken this long but at least we've done
it and we can show now
what
people were beginning to get clues of in
the 1950s and 60s these are
a very powerful alternative way of
helping people with mental illness the
authors say while the findings are
encouraging patients should not
self-medicate with psilocybin
the findings bode well for research on
other mental illnesses professor nutt's
team is currently studying the use of
psychedelics for anorexia
[Music]
you